what are we trying to prove while we're
trying to prove that it's np-hard to
approximate max 3sat between within
seven eight eight plus Epsilon and for
reason that's still obscure and maybe
not so well motivated I said I would do
max real in instead and then get a
constant half plus Epsilon
and something I sort of felt guilty
about as I sort of I used two terms
completeness and soundness over and over
again I never defined them completeness
is the probability to accept a correct
proof of a correct statement soundness
is the maximum probability to accept
something that's incorrect an incorrect
statement and then I had some background
we had I'd said PCP I never told you
what PCP swear their probabilities
checkable proofs and the PCP theorem
says that with there's a polynomial size
proof that with you know order log and
random coins you have a proof that reads
a constant number of bits which has
completeness one and a soundness that's
an absolute constant less than one and
then I did the two prover game turn this
into a to prove a game in it well first
I actually assumed that this was first I
sort of cheating Lee assume that this
was three and then I turned into this to
it to prove ur game
of course the PCP theorem is a difficult
theorem and I didn't prove it I just
stated it and then then this to prove a
game I you said you could play this in
parallel and then you you kept the
compact completeness and you improve the
soundness much as you wanted depending
on the number of repetitions and then I
abstracted away this this to prove a
game to a label cover game where you
have a small side and a big side
corresponding to the to prove errs and
the task and free and your edge is going
across and each edge is a projection and
the task is to make labels for these
things
that respect the projection and the
completeness of this proof system is one
that you know in the good case you can
find labels that satisfy all the all the
constraints and the soundness is epsilon
where epsilon is this number and then in
the I said well what we actually should
do in this label coverage should we
should replace each label by it by a big
table which was supposed to be the long
code and the long code a correct long
code is simply something that takes the
corresponding inputs and outputs the
corresponding coordinate corresponding
to the label and on top of it I wanted
the long codes these tables to have the
properties that they respect negation
and then I said I would choose three
inputs x y&z the first two randomly and
then the last one essentially to be the
product of the first two with
probability 1 minus Delta and with
probability dealt I set it to something
else and before we continue I just want
it to be brutally concrete I mean
somehow nothing is very hard here but I
wanted really to see you know what is
this proof like okay now I should also
so let's just see what this proof system
would look like suppose I fix the label
here in the label there I was sorry a
position there in a position there and
the small set actually has two different
labels and the big set has four
different levels and the projection this
very edge happens to be that in Mac 0
and 1 2 0 & & 2 & 3 2 1 and somehow I
specified the supposed loan codes and F
should really be something that map's 2
bits to a single bit right because this
is 2 but since it's forced to respect
negation I just need to make the table
for the entries of
having one in the first position and I
will know what we're gonna do when
there's a minus one in the position
we'll take that thing and negate it
you're happy with this and G is a
function of three bits and I just need
to specify it for all the inputs that
start with a one so let's start so
what's f you here coding the second bit
excellent you disqualified yourself on
top so what does G here code as I get
this right yeah cause the third bit yeah
right so now I don't do my protocol I
pick two random inputs okay and you
don't trust my randomness anyhow but I I
picked X to be this random input and Y
to be this and the input and then let's
see how we should compute Z so let's
assume Delta is small numbers let's
assume that there are no errors that's
actually so then what should zb1
one more - woman
1 1 minus 1 1 so how do we calculate
this well the well I should start
I shouldn't smidge yeah so what's this
one well we should take this
corresponding coordinate in Y and we
should take the corresponding coordinate
in the projection of X right so if you
see that PI project 0 to 0 so this one
is the X the X or which is just a
multiplication of these two bits
similarly this thing is the
multiplication of this spit on that bit
since PI also Maps 1 to 0 right and then
this is the XOR of this and this bit
since you know it maps to 2 1 and maps 3
to 1 so that section okay
so let's try to compute F on this okay
well minus 1 1 is not in the table but
it's actually the minus of this so f of
X is actually 1 it's minus F of 1 minus
1 do you why well we have minus 1 minus
1 minus 1 1 and then we we'd need to
negate everything so vit but we have 1 1
1 minus 1 so it's minus G of 1 1 1 minus
1 which is 1 and G of Z but there were
too many are you to get chocolates for
that one and G of C will yes we have to
look 1 1 1 minus 1 1 and it's a minus 1
and you see the product of these 3 bits
are 1 and then we should accept ok yeah
I also claimed some properties of this
protocol which I'll recap soon but this
is sort of the setup of the protocol so
are you all happy so in the end you know
this was sort of important to set up but
if you just remember that the label
cover will be with well it's not
completely - we might have to go back a
little bit later but for now we'll just
use the label cover or is everybody
happy with things
outside the name for this way don't you
think I've forgot to write down a
vehicle
Yohann you you misspelled completeness
there nah trivial misspellings is
mathematical trivial mathematical errors
will really cost chocolates per genomes
obviously Hispanics will not okay
so the Sun is the story the completeness
lemma I did last time saying that if a
correct labeling of a living that
satisfies everything and you just follow
this recipe use the long coats here and
then you check this this equation and
that satisfy exactly when you choose
this alternative on the important input
the correct labeling so where you are
happy with this what you want to see
this again anybody I'll show this again
okay so what's happening in an error
when we pick u and W so the point is
that right so by the definition of the
long coat this should be the very
coordinate for which you're coding
because G and for the same reason GW y
is y with the same thing and a few of X
is X to the label corresponding sorry
that's what happens in a correct true
for a correct statement but important
repeat until now is that PI of lambda W
is lambda u it means that with
probability 1 minus Delta where Z
right because that's what how we define
the probability distribution on the X Y
Z's so we really set up everything to
just have a very easy completeness you
know a correct proof of a correct Smith
statement is sort of it's one should see
what it does
so the importance on this lemons now
that says if you have a good proof in
this with this acceptance criteria and
good here will be that you accept with
probability at least half plus gamma I
call this Delta prime but and sort of
this formula became difficult to read
last time so if you accept with
probability that's a little bit more
than a half then in fact you're going to
extract the labeling that does something
interesting for the label cover Singh
and it will in fact satisfy a fraction
of the label that depends only on this
number and the defining number here in
the
and the point the the logic now is that
if you set up saying so that this is
actually bigger than epsilon which we
know was the soundness of the label
cover then we know that such a thing
cannot exist so the next thing I want
you to do is she actually start proving
this some Islam I think or do I need to
review how that gave the approximability
for next tool in my Mac thrillin that
was sort of this the bad prover right
that sort of sets himself to optimize
the best proof and then it's really the
completeness over the sound that just
the approximation ratio there you know
this unscrupulous prove or the just try
to optic convince the verifies as
quickly as possible well if you have to
return to this will return to this later
but will okay
yeah I'll go spell it spell doesn't
Islam nevermind so we live fix you know
let's fix the edge picked which sort of
means that and from now on I'll use FG
and and pie without indices you know F F
depends on you G depends on W and the
projection depends on both but let's
ignore this
so let's let's write down some arbitrary
quantity here I mean the product of f of
X G of Y and G of Z what do we know
about this yeah
so this is you're saying that this is to
gamma right if I and I'm are usually
well let's let's do like let's make my
life a little bit harder and I don't
have to drag this to belong expectation
this is just gamma right sorry
so let's see how what it looks like so
now I'll just replace this by the free
expansion so
so we just have well we've seen the for
expansion in the two other talks and I
hope I can do this without technology so
we'll replace this and this and this so
this expectation that looks at
expectations
let's let's do it carefully
what
I realized this already because yeah
changing this Delta prime to gamma was a
bad thing but that we have to live with
this you have to improvise sometimes
okay
into a lot yes you just expand the sum
so you get the hideous three big sums
and then you you know expectations go
inside the sums and then we just have to
look at this thing okay and then we have
to remember is everybody happy with this
you know you expand it you know exchange
to the waters of expectations and sums
so let's see
Thanks so this is what it actually says
right in the plus/minus MA notation the
characters are just the product so let's
take the expectation of this so what the
main thing we want to do is we want to
say that this is zero most of the time
anybody who hasn't seen this who can
actually figure out some terms that are
zero yes
I mean the hi yes this level slightly
beautiful three this lives so different
to make them so I should really have to
know s and L and earlier right yes that
what you're saying but even there I
suppress the third side the expansion is
correct right I'm saying this um is it
something we have to take into account
yes surely
so let's see
okay so my first claim is that if you
look at the term like this and these two
sets are not the same I claim that the
expectation is in fact zero okay and the
reason is you know suppose we fix X well
it's Y is random independent bit zi is
very dependent on Y I bet independent on
everything else so unless both Zi and
why I appear simultaneously will be will
be fine okay
I get some curious this is just
orthogonality of these for you paratis
essentially
rejection of fan
one
as well if the yeah so I'm fixing let's
fix X so let me just have to then this
is just a constant right and now I'm
just worrying the random choices over
wise and Z's and I claim me if you look
at why I am Zi they're both independent
their residences it would be zero as
well alpha oh good good good yes yes sir
you're moving ahead you're not okay why
inti a dependent right at what why I and
Zi prime are independently yes yes so
the second CIA should be CI prime no no
no no Arabs and trainers with the Santos
depends of everything except each other
right so CI appears in this and why I
does not appear we're fine it was this
mathematically clear statement yeah
thanks okay so we
so in the case that you don't know it
yeah I don't I don't need the noise for
this no I'm saying that if that is the
intent I love this I mean if it is 0 it
would be fine it's like okay after you
fix that noise yeah you can be with in
various ways but you know there's still
no sore no noise they're still
independent own so this means that we
know sort of and I had already forgotten
the beta Prime there so it's fine right
so this is we can discard all the terms
for beta is not equal to beta prime let
me get something like this so now with
the question we had some who was trying
to get the chocolate thereby getting rid
of some more terms do you want to
continue with beta and also live on
different spaces right position yeah
okay so you're claiming that
okay
it is
yeah
so George's
does everybody agreed to this you want
to do it the other way around
now we have a different better or less
all right this is what you're carrying
oh sorry sorry Jess now we maybe have to
be equal okay so let's let's sum each of
this two statement will you claim is to
correct them which implies which implies
that the term is zero
and who takes out smoke well let's try
to make this a little bit more
transparent
okay so let's write this as mu I times X
pi I times y I but the probability that
mu I is 1 is 1 minus Delta and the
probability that minus 1 is Delta okay
is that what you that's the best I can
do so I'll sort of explicitly do this
error and then everything is sort of
independent
right look at this right so now we saw
that this is a bias variable and we sort
of have the Y's and we can cross out the
Y's since then 2 plus minus ones that in
fact it's great to one
so now you see well well I shall come on
I'm sorry that was an excellent
suggestion sorry
whoops I'm sorry about that one please
redirect yeah so now we can look at this
is this always zero but the point is
that we have to have a product of excise
which are sort of uniformly random
things why do we have an empty product
or we get zero
so my claim is that the only way we can
get an expectation that stone serum is
that if all the J's that appear in alpha
something appears in alpha if and only
if there's an odd number of eyes that
project onto this thing which sort of
means that we do have this condition but
we do not really have this condition
because an odd number of betas that
project so an even number of betas the
projections of the same thing will
actually cancel each other this one this
is the noise thingy that I did try to
introduce here we refer to this equation
I expanded I had to pay that beta prime
right yes and then I claim that unless
beta was equal to beta prime it was zero
so then I kept only the beta terms and
then I'm done I had Y items Zi and then
I just replaced CI fights definition see
I was was now the error vector x they
expected times the Y vector and then I
canceled the Y vectors and then I
checked that you know to cancel the
expect that we needed this
so this I'll use the short turn saying
that I'll face the mode to projection of
paper
I'll have this this is exactly this
condition so beta uniquely defines our
farm I buy this property
so everything has canceled now expect
this error vectors new I and I only keep
the terms for alpha this is something
overall and this was even do it like
this right to a beta and just give two
to the first light did you do to the
second one if your phone does a mapping
of sense but this pi tube condition I
don't know what is equivalent I mean
that's I mean I'm sort of done lifting
and having an element that lives on this
smaller space right and I'm lifting it
to an vector on the big space right X is
really living on the small space but and
I said let's look at it something on the
big space by taking everything that
projects onto J to be XJ and that's what
it is I don't know terrific I don't want
to say this better maybe there's an
abstract side
well we can so now we just need this
expected value okay but totally this
expected value is very easy because you
know the new eyes are just random bits
that's you know one with a certain
probability minus one with a different
probability so I claim that what we get
or maybe somebody should learn in
chocolate what's the expected value here
but - to say the P 1 - 2 - the size of
it so this is what we have right so we
have that gamma is in fact equal to this
gamma you know that the acceptance
probability over 1/2 we just dropped all
the term service here we calculate an
expected value perfect
yes the expectation is to the sine of
beta
- what like to take my weights 1 Delta H
to the power of beta in - eh - pulpit no
I mean stunt independent for each eye
right we're not treating the things with
the projection yeah yeah okay okay
so better yeah I cheated you we do have
you know still expectation of U and V
outside this really
Oh could you repeat the question yes but
I mean the only terms that remain is
when this set released the mode to
projection of this thing sorry I can
repeat the question I don't know true
without this term this as you know that
receivers just something or over an
alpha is gone you just some oval beta
right
I had a sum over alpha then beta sin
beta primes and now just reduce it to
some of beta yeah so first I noted that
you know pate that time had to be equal
to beta produce um to be nonzero so I
could drop the summation over beta Prime
and then I noted that alpha has to be
equal to the mode to projection of beta
unless the sum 0 so I can drop to sum
over alpha a this condition yes yeah
okay so
so the question is now what's the best
thing to do but I'll try a different way
compared to do it usually so
so what will I do now you know I'm
supposed to take these Fourier
coefficients and I'm actually going to
jump to the end of the proof and define
the good labeling you know how do you
extract the good labeling from the how
are you going to eventually extract the
good lately
so claim that the labeling will
construct this actually astronaut what
does it do well it's supposed to get an
element to the left which corresponds to
function so what we'll do is we'll
simply take the the the corresponding
Fourier coefficients and we'll return a
random element in this Fourier
coefficients this is what we'll do on
both sides
so now we can worry about lots of things
so anybody's worried about anything
you know we have to check that these are
reasonable strategies at first I decide
you know problem is this a good
probability to start with yes yeah and
that's another problem I'll face the
empty set that's also a two things two
to lots of things to worry about here
okay that's a good worry thank you ie
sorry has something should practice this
more you know we're sitting front if
you're going to say something
let's ship this
okay haven't exploited before the years
right so we had let's we sort of have a
gamma as they fight to beta
she had beta squared of one month
damn
what
the NSA if there yeah you can worry
about both there so first one this was
the first worry right so anybody sees
the f is an odd function
yeah so even for your computer's you
know your nostrils like that right but
that's like yeah
so right behind at F of minus X is minus
f of X which means that f at empty cent
which is just a expectation of F is in
fact zero
I mean we really have that atlatl alpha
is equal to zero as long as the size of
alpha is even but this this doesn't
matter for us I mean really care of only
about the empty cell so this little says
that ok this really says that you're
known them to the containers is one of
them ok so the next thing is that if
this is not maybe not even going to have
a chocolate these are actually
probabilities right there is some to one
so but successes well the key thing to
analyze so
let's me
so that so I claim that the success
probability at least if you sound if for
your coefficients take all the sets that
actually do intersect and um let's do it
the person alpha is actually subsets
over the projection of beta when I claim
well the probability of picking said
alpha is this probability over picking
betas at least this um and once you've
sort of fixed the choice of a random J
in beta the probability that will course
there is at least one I that projects
onto it and the probability of picking
this is at least this
or better eyes you know fix yourself J
in alpha and then the probability we
have at least one good eye in in beta
since we know that something projects on
it so and the probability of picking
this is at least one over the size of it
well yeah so if I say well instead of
picking the day is a subset let's say
that the restricted some to an alphas
exactly fight to obey that there's going
to be more because you know the pi/2
projection is always a subset of the
projection right I claim that if I
change the condition to this the success
is still good
so now I only have to compare this right
so now I have one expression that I know
is large well I have one success
probability that sort of looks a little
bit the same and I must now just want to
compare these two guys
you know you just have to be a little
bit smarter than I was in I wrote the
paper first place so you want to use
Cauchy Schwartz
so if you use course rights put on this
um we sort of had the beliefs or number
smaller than once it's sort of we have
the square here and we sort of yourself
the first term here so let's see if
Scottish rights and we'll see that we
get the square here and then we split
this into two factors some one and push
one to the other side of the cauchy
schwarz
I don't know if this is of course it's
righteous magic to admit there are other
ways to do this and but then this second
thing is more than one right because
it's yen again plunger up so this is
smaller than you know just taking this
thing up
so old it so let's see what we have
it should be telescope
was
there should be two beta Thanks so this
sort of says that you know we look at
yeah my small and and this is since
expectations of squares works nicely you
know the expectation of the squares
parent it's more than the square of the
expectation we see that gamma square is
smaller than this so this is large so we
just need to compare these two things
and well the simplest
let's stretch like this
shoes then I guess have to observe that
the in fact this for small Fitness this
is a little bit larger but it's never
larger one more than a factor of Delta
and emerald um like we define this
strategy with the success probability
and since this term wise is in fact
greater than a factor of Delta x this
and this is lease gamma squared we are
now done and that's sort of the end of
the soundness part
any questions or thoughts or so this
means that this is greater than tough
that times gamma squared just this
it's great to them and that's that's the
strategy for the that's the
probabilistic labeling that we get yeah
yeah why does it work that sort of why
doesn't yeah this is a bad bound it's
all yeah it's it's it's it's all natural
bound when the size of pea types of I
mean if it's not the very bad bound I
think but the point I mean you can sort
of see I mean when you set up this
strategy you can set up the strategy by
the Fourier coefficients and you say
well you're immediately come what if
these Fourier coefficients are large
okay because then you'll have big big
huge sets to choose from but the point
is you need some damping factor here
that sort of says that the big betas
won't contribute to the accept
probability in the pcp and exactly how
quickly this the case will sort of
relate to the sets of the betas I mean
this the sizes of the sets and you know
the and the probabilities so the faster
the case the better but this decays
pretty nicely
is that the intuition behind the best
yes ma'am I don't know why you can't
have perfect completeness so then I did
you know I don't remember what I was
thinking when I decided this is the
first time there's a long time ago now
in retrospect you got all these good
arguments but someone when you when you
prove things you just fiddle around with
and then something suddenly works and
then you're sort of go back and analyze
it
but it was clear you couldn't have
perfect completeness right when you go
for max readings you have to create some
errors and this was seemed like a
natural way to distribution which is
I don't know what you mean once is the
reason well I want to prove hardness
from max 3sat was what I what you really
want to do right yes what this one yeah
I mean this was the successful
probability of the strategy I defined
right this was the except probability in
the PCP I mean what sort of derived from
the success probability to the PCP so
the conclusion of this was that if the
success probability in the PCP is high
then this success strategy is successful
correct maybe I didn't spell out this
point right this this is the success
probability of this strategy I wrote
down pick around the mouth of it this
probability random beta with this
probability and then just random
elements yeah that's the labeling
probability labeling strategy so the way
to prove it these words will have
probabilities to compare it with the
success probability of the PCP which we
assume is big right and these are in
fact that's bigger than that term wines
apart from the factor Delta I mean these
are what post I mean everything is
positive here so we can do it turn back
to no no I'm sorry
thanks for
good okay so that's sort of ends this
really proof so now we can try to do
three set okay
but this sort of does this
so in fact if you think about it for a
while you know as thrilling condition is
just in fact equivalent to a four closes
in three cell and I hope I got it right
I need the other way around yeah thanks
so in fact something that satisfies this
satisfies this will satisfy only
foreclosures
so
um
and
right so as I can take book the most
simple abhorrent edit reductions so just
replace one condition of these by four
conditions and it has the property that
if this is satisfied then I satisfied
forecloses and if it's not satisfying
satisfies three out of the four toast
so thank if you just look at the TV just
do this translation if you can satisfy a
fraction 1 minus epsilon on the courses
in the max trillion you get 4 minus
epsilon of the things over there and if
you don't have plus epsilon you get 3
and 1/2 plus absolute alright and then
you see you know like picking episome
suitably this is X close as you want to
7/8 so we're actually done yes yeah but
that's an excellent question
when worth of a chocolate yes know the
reasoning is randomized but the the
reduction itself is in fact
deterministic so it's all I mean we're
talking a probabilistic terms but in
fact if you looked at the entire game
looking at all the random right ponds
option father I'm always always looking
at the one the random choices of the
verify right and I'm sort of making
copies for all the so there's no so that
the the it is a deterministic reduction
okay
so the other question is excellent right
the first question is well this is sort
of it gives the right approximation
factor but it doesn't give us what we
want right right I never promised mind
you I only promised you an approximation
result
but maybe what you were thinking all
along is that this is sort of an
aesthetically not very pleasing right
you would really want in a positive case
to satisfy all the clauses but the ratio
is too fine I mean I said I can get the
operator very close to seven eight seven
but it's a good point and this is what
we're going to do next right I mean this
is what we kind of worked a lot harder
for but before we going to work a lot
harder let us I said you know we can do
a gadget reduction but what's sort of
the obvious way you're going to make a
PCP I mean what's the obvious very of
proving in approximability yourself well
why did we get max real in here it's
because we check the linear equations
and the bits of the proof so we really
want to check this first two to check
the 3sat condition instead
so let's do this
so let's make the final check here
instead a three-set condition instead of
checking a linear equation the first of
all what happens to completeness I'm
still folding the code right yeah so
that's like I never had to check a
question sequel to minus 1 I mean equal
to 2 yet I don't need I mean this will
be some implicit negations and these
things depending on the folding right so
when you translate it to it well you
just have to check that these 3 bits are
unlikely to be 1 1 1 and in the current
proof they actually are but suppose we
do like this since that has to be on the
safe side okay then I came you know
completeness will work exactly as before
we just see well if these are correct
coatings of correct things and these
three bits will be the corresponding
three coordinates of the Y's and they
will with extremely low probability all
before
okay with probability that Delta
so you're happy with this change to the
verify I have the same probability this
a change the sign here yes W wishes but
essentially the same probability
distribution or XY z-- and C's and now I
just checked a very different condition
and then I hope to get the results for
max 3sat and stuff good okay so now
there are two things that I act so now
you sort of want to set up the Machine
and say well I prove the soundness where
we check this other condition I want to
prove the soundness pretty reaction to
check this work condition you know will
this work equally nicely and then there
you want to modify the distribution here
so that you always accept right
so the ideas for this where were you any
comments on either of these two things
yes you have of course it's a bit
extreme a difficult question because we
want to analyze it so you want to sorry
I have stopped you in the middle you
wanted to say something
all right so remember that Falls is one
so the really thing I mean when you're
going to choose some new distribution
the X Y Z's what you really want is that
these three bits should never
simultaneously take the values 1 1 1
because then you're loose that's how you
yeah so now you we have
that was the annuity now so this is
I think
I don't know what if this happened
before your each was born more less Lord
I think it's happened before sheltered
academia but here what she did was
taking this I'm not sure what paper
you're referring yeah I need it first
that's all so let's see let's see what
what what what conditions should we have
on these three bits right so we had one
suggestion here you know yeah yeah so
you said we pick X randomly that's what
you said and then we pick Y randomly and
then you said you know with put CI equal
to if these what if these are both false
well so let's
let's do what you
let's try the other thing we had
so this is more or less what you said
right so any stylistic opinions on this
okay
so first of all something I never really
said what's the difference between y and
z here in my original in the original we
said it is are they the same or they're
different they're correlated but it's X
or Y or the Y & Z or the I mean you can
just change to if you pick Z run so my
point is that this is their really
symmetric right so it is symmetric here
okay so they're not symmetric which is
sort of a holistic you own then an x and
y are random is the question is Z a
random yeah sorry yeah is it uniformly
distributed this
is it or is it not it's the dangerous
that sees is not uniform and the problem
is that
the bits that produced the I and Zi
prime with the same projection
or quarterly
okay
and the reason is that that the X for
this projected value happens to be one
then they're both more like then they're
more likely to be one because you're
like the wise okay so when everyone on
the input is both sort of not uniform
you could get get into lots of trouble
you really want them to be uniform if X
is 1 then
set by Z to be 1 minus 1 or minus 1 1
otherwise you choose the same thing
yes sir so let's see if I we got this
right
so we
so the thing I actually want to do is
that if it if the corresponding X is
false and I'll set Y and Zi to be
opposite with probability 1 well if you
already expire is minus 1 then then we
don't have to care so much and then I
for symmetry reason I'll set them equal
with high probability and I need for bit
small problem so this is effective apart
from how you vary Delta this is the only
way I have to get the distribution so
that avoids 1 1 1 and such that y and z
are uniformly distributed we don't get
any pair words why is it the minus sign
up yeah why you want it
you know why is it why don't they flip
them with probability 1 minus Delta why
don't you want CI equal to minus y well
so let's see if I will see that from the
analysis eventually ok but what happens
is well if you look at just y&z now this
sort of says that in this case they're
most often not equal ok so some of it
you want to be as random as possible so
when you have the possibility of certain
equals often this book but that's yeah
so this is in fact the probability
district do you
that's an excellent yeah we're actually
very close to the parity distribution
that's another right this is saying sort
of that the product of XYZ almost always
this minus one okay and this not obvious
why this is true but this is really
close to the parent distribution that's
a good point it's not clear a priori why
this is beneficial but that's we
succeeded there and if you change little
bit do well again so we are let close to
the opposite of the parity right and the
Virgin is we knew we wanted that the
product of the three yeah but thank you
I cheated I already did this oh yeah 30
distributions already this yeah and what
I wanted to change this to - yeah to
make sure that we are almost always
satisfied so that then and it's very
close to that distribution right
so let's
so let's try to start the analysis and
we won't really finish it so let's have
this test that we get two different
distribution that both is sort of the
negation of the parity distribution this
distribution that actually gives us the
perfect completeness or you have this
will give us the perfect completeness
here we'll have a PCP where the verifier
always accepts right if you should I
write this down
because in a correct proof of a correct
statement you'll read three such bits
and if the first doesn't do it for you
one of the second to the other two will
definitely do
was it
that's right like this
okay so if you think of this condition
you know
this kind of or conditions are not so
nice when you sort of like Fourier
transforms and real numbers so let's
write this as a real number thing
instead so I claim that in fact the all
of these things is this thing in the
sense that this is one if there were is
true and this is zero if there is false
this is in fact the three bit Fourier
transform of the word function if you
want it yeah yeah now this is the
Swedish thing you have this little I
can't that's a seven in the US right
okay so now you want to say well you
would say if this accepted probability
greater than seven eight
then in fact expectation of one of these
things has to be big okay so let's do it
first in the very simple case you know
when we had this this the same
distribution essentially except for the
minus sign and the parity so what can
you say on the expectations of all these
terms
by this time I mean this distribution so
the expectation of f of X what's the
expectation of f of X y 1 yes
XS y only the formula submitted term we
have folding right
how about this thing yeah we're in fact
independent may have folding okay
and it's these the same maybe yes agree
that they're symmetric so how about a
disturbance or y&z independent they're
not independent right because things
that project onto the same thing or
but they find that I claim that if you
look at the input X Y Z in minus X Y and
minus Z they're in fact equally likely
because you know if you just change X to
minus X to change the e to minus Z and
we have exactly the same and in fact
these terms will cancel each other
because you know X doesn't appear and
so this means that you know since we can
take care of all terms except possibly
the last term if the acceptance of this
is higher than seven days spices you
know that that seven eight plus some
gamma this means that this we have an
minus sign
this means that expectation of this
thing it has to be big right and you
know we actually get the minus sign
which is exactly the minus sign since I
changed the Z so now we have exactly the
same situation as we had with the parity
right all the other terms disappear and
that's it but now we have this
distribution is that okay let's
so we have this new distribution which
is shown on one over here let's call
this distribution D sad so now we took
so before we died just to care of all
these terms what happens to these terms
in this situation can we I said if you
had the past
distributions this was the only guy that
we needed to care about right what yes
so let's
so we still have you know both
independence you know between X and and
the Y X and the Z
so I claim that already this term will
give you problems
okay and I was had planned to do this
but time is up and it might even be a B
so this is now homework until tomorrow
we meet tomorrow at eleven okay start
estimating disturbance e up for you get
you know we need to prove right the way
to prove first of all I mean one bad
thing is we we just have the long code
of one of the tables will be never gonna
extract if this term is big
we will never extract a strategy of the
to prove a citizen's right because we
only have essentially one side we have a
G which only lives some of the
distribution of y and z will tell you
something about the smaller table but
your question is can you use this in
such case to extract the strategy so yes
just so that how will you go ahead and
estimate this value that's the first
step in the calculation could anybody
guess what that would be yes you should
expand the Fourier transform it and take
it term by term and go from there and
see if you can do it term by term
okay so we'll continue at 11:00 tomorrow